[Music]
as shown in the previous videos
now we have a really efficient method of
doing multiple pattern matching using
the burrows wheeler transform
but finding exact pattern matches might
not be able to answer our question to
identify variants when compared to the
reference genome
so we need to look for inexact matching
in order to find these variants
in general there are two methods for
identification of variants
one is called the seating method and
another is the burrows wheeler approach
as described previously
in the seating method assuming we have a
pattern appears in a genome with exactly
one mismatch
if we divide the pattern into two pieces
we will notice that one side is going to
match the genome exactly
and another side of the partition has
the mismatch
in general if we have a pattern that
occurs in the genome with d mismatches
then we are going to be able to divide
the pattern into d plus one
approximately equal pieces and then we
are going to be able to find at least
one of those pieces that matches the
genome exactly
for example here is a string of 35 axes
assume that we have six mismatches with
the reference
if you partition this into seven pieces
with equal length
we will have at least one partition that
have an exact match with the genome
hence whenever we have 18 mismatches if
we divide this pattern into d
plus one pieces we will always have at
least one partition that has exact match
with the genome
this is the principle of the seating
method if we are looking for demis
matches we can divide each of the
pattern strings into d
plus one smaller pieces and these pieces
are called seeds
and then we look for exact matches of
those seeds with our genome
once we find those exact matches it
narrows down what we have to consider
so we can throw out a lot of patterns
and then look for inexact matches based
on those seed matches
another way to identify the variants
would be to integrate a direct burrows
wheeler approach
recall that when we looked at pattern
matching before with burroughs wheeler
we search for a a and panama bananas
we started with finding the a and we
walked backwards to the other column of
the burroughs-wheeler matrix
and we could find three n's we had an a
and then an n and we would immediately
eliminate the m
the p and the b because they didn't
match the n that we were looking for
if we were allowing one mismatch then we
need to keep these red letters around
we need to hold on to them because it
may be the case that we can continue
extending
and get exact matches everywhere else
and then we would have an inexact match
with one mismatch
what we'll need to do next is to keep
track of the number of mismatches that
we've encountered along the way
here we've encountered zero mismatches
when we've matched these ends
because we have two matched symbols here
we've encountered one mismatched set the
m
the p and the b because we haven't
exceeded one mismatch
we'll need to extend all these strings
we'll use the first last property and
take all of the pattern here and find
where each of these elements occurs back
in the first
column we know that the a is going to be
there next
so we carry the mismatches down and we
have more mismatches here
so we need to eliminate this next we
need to identify where those mismatches
are located
we will use a suffix array to identify
where the inexact matches occurred
we find that there is one mismatch in
position 5 and position 3
while position 1 7 and 9
give us the exact matches with the huge
arsenal of power using burroughs wheeler
were able to easily step forward and
deal with inexact matches now